back home to be buried
the 13 turkish police and military
personnel had been discovered in a cave
in northern iraq on sunday
turkey says they had been abducted and
then executed by fighters of the
kurdistan workers party
or pkk during a combat operation
[Music]
but turkey's anger for the killings
wasn't just directed at the outlet group
now there is a statement made by the
united states it's a joke
were you not supposed to stand against
the terrorists the pkk
the ypg and the pyd you clearly support
them and stand behind them
the pkk is listed as a terrorist
organization not only by turkey
but the u.s and the eu the u.s condemned
the killings
if responsibility lay with the pkk
if we work together with you and nato if
we are to continue our unity in the
world and nato
then you will act sincerely towards us
then you will stand with us
not with the terrorists
ankara was already angered by
washington's support of kurdish fighters
in neighboring
syria turkey claims the group known as
ypg
is organically tied to the pkk and the
name difference is just a branding
effort
to legitimize the organization in the
fight against isil
infuriated by washington's statement on
the iraq killings
turkey summoned the u.s ambassador to
ankara
and later turkey's foreign minister
spoke for the first time with his new
u.s counterpart
anthony blinken according to readouts
blinken is said to have affirmed that
pkk was to blame
and the two emphasized the importance of
their bilateral relationship
and interest in countering terrorism but
the differences between the
long-standing
allies remain as a nato ally ankara
wants washington to pick aside either
turkey
or the pkk and the syrian-based ypg
but in january in coming u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken accused turkey
of
not acting like an ally because of his
purchase of a russian air defense system
and said the u.s would review if further
sanctions are required
unless one side compromises the dispute
between nato's two biggest armies
may not end soon cnn cosolo al jazeera
istanbul